19
i made a visit to mariupol and that time
in marupu we could still
hear shots and
fire
we we could hear the sound when the wind
was blowing towards marupo so it was
quite close
i know these details uh
now i'm aware of this so i want the
people respected people like yourselves
to to be there and to be able to go
there of course
we do not see
a bigger escalation that it has been
before yet
friends they called upon russia to pull
back i don't think the situation is is
more intense than
it was at that time at the peak time in
early 2021 it was very intense
but
such
informational
uh attitude towards ukraine and this
question not only to you but to the
world there was no such coverage at that
time of ukraine
and uh we've talked to the president
we've talked to about this we think that
it has to be
once approached i'm not saying that they
he's influencing uh american media
they're independent but
the media policy there has to be
well-balanced if they want to know what
the situation is that they they can come
to kiev do we have tanks on the street
no
but the feeling is if you're not here
the feeling is when you listen to them
in germany in in
in france in lithuania i'm talking to
the president of lithuania and other
leaders the
the
image that mass media creates is that we
have troops on the roads we have
mobilization people are leaving for
places that's not the case we don't need
this panic
that's a very important moment i'm not
saying
that
that escalation is excluded
we have been talking about this for
eight years now it has happened to red
the escalation did already happen part
of our territories already unfortunately
temporarily occupied we understand that
already
and
economically
and i mentioned this to president biden
and i think the u.s supporter i said
that i started talking to the leaders of
the countries and to explain
uh to them that we need to stabilize the
economy of our country
because of
those signals which say that tomorrow
there will be because this signals were
sent by even respected leaders of the
respected countries that sometimes they
are not even using diplomatic language
they're saying tomorrow is the war
this means panic on the market panic in
the financial sector maybe i'm taking
too long to answer the question is it
okay
it's okay
so how much does it cost to a country
you have to i mean i want you to
understand these things
we need unity of our people
people have to be certain and sure in
their army in their president
the people should trust their government
and their special services we are
grateful for any support but this varied
information from varied sources
cannot mislead our country because this
raises economic panic i just give you
the example how much it costs
we have the record-breaking gdp in 2021
record-breaking number we have
the growth in a short period of time we
had about almost 6.5 of new investments
in 2021
but
after
i think
after
the beginning of this informational
coverage
after this change in the information
coverage uh 12 and a half billion
has taken of worth of investment
out of ukraine
and from our
golden reserves which is the highest in
the last 10 years
our country can you understand we we
can't handle this
alone from the
public reserves from the state reserves
we have to take money and to stabilize
our national currency this is what we're
trying to explain this costs
very lo that's a lot it's very expensive
price to pay for ukraine
and this is the price we're paying for
the unbalanced and reasonable
information policy
and that's
one of the deep questions and this is
why i'm explaining this they're saying
that we have some misunderstanding we
don't have any misunderstandings with
president i just
deeply understand what is going on in my
country just as he understands perfectly
well what's going on in the united
states that's it
so we we're done with about money
bloomberg do we do we have bloomberg
here in the room
yes please if you have a question over
there
behind the cameras
thank you uh you mentioned
money
what is your assessment of
the needs
of ukraine in terms of funds and if
we're talking about borrowing
borrowing from which countries and which
institutions and when thank you very
much for this question
this is not just uh lending is a
question of financial guarantees
the question is in in sending
proper good signals
um this should can be investments or
financial guarantees which can be
provided by a country it's not even the
matter of
numbers just for us to understand how
this works we
we've talked to the leaders of certain
states of the united states of canada
canada proposed 120 million and this is
the message this is the signal i think
france will respond the united states
will respond we we ask them for
uh
10 times more than that and that was our
request i don't know
whether we will
get the support or not and what demand
that will be
but generally we had a conversation also
with the eu we will be getting the micro
financial assistance we agreed about one
about 1.2
billion
and other
funds as well we
what we mean is sending the signal of by
different countries the eu
the united states canada
by any friends and partners of ukraine
and
i think that for the stabilization of
our economy
we will spend
what i think about
four or five billion
i'm not
expecting anything less than that so
so that's the money we need right now
but the question is is not in the in the
size of the of the of the of this but uh
the question is that this is the signal
of trust to ukraine to the stability of
the economy of ukraine for example if
imf
their a program is higher than uh 2
billion dollars this is the signal that
we're expecting
and we're expecting for for for these
tranches to to come faster and
cnn plays the floor as yours
right
thank you very much uh for giving me
this question
um
what do you tell me that you need most
of all from the united states that it is
not doing to help you better confront
and deter russia
what are you asking for that he's not
giving me
thank you for this question
i uh have a good uh memory of the face i
think we met in donbass didn't we
and i think you saw
it for yourself you have seen our
courageous people
i think you
saw that we all
want peace but we
protect our country because i'm not just
the president i'm uh
the husband
i'm the son
[Music]
i'm the father we have things that we
want to protect and
that's why i'm discussing these
questions in detail with president biden
i want everyone
to be on the same page as where i am so
i i they don't need to love ukraine as
well much as i do you have your own
country but at least i want you to
get to grips with what we are facing and
the risks and the details
this is why the questions that we have
been discussing with the president uh by
far not
the first time
we
are the questions after the event uh and
this is the question not only to
president biden well i don't have any
separate questions for him personally
this is europe and many other countries
who are talking about this
so there are countries who still
mentioned there are some preventive
measures that can be introduced to make
sure that russia doesn't escalate
what we mean is that there should be
security guarantees when we are talking
about nato
we should
[Music]
go deeper into detail i know that
some
members of nato don't like us going into
this detail but we want to have
something specific
we need to have something that we can
count on
uh first of all security guarantees if
we're talking about nato and the second
is the level of our army
no matter when we get into
nato or whether we will be there at all
nothing in this case depends on
us
not everything depends on us we have to
develop our own army we have to protect
ourselves but we understand
right now perfectly well that if we are
not part of nato then we are on our own
in terms of protecting ourselves and
when you are on our own protecting
yourself
when you are single-handedly
facing a very uh
difficult uh uh country uh in front of
you then you ask a question why is these
sanctions applied after the fact
is it uh does this pertain to ukraine
no i i don't uh think what will happen
after this
will there be a full-fledged war then
why do we need sanctions after it starts
after the beginning of the war
so
the the it means that these sanctions
are not designed for our country to help
our country this because
this is uh to stop the full-fledged
aggression towards the european union
but this cannot be done at the expense
of our country
that's not the way to do it we had 15
000 deaths
in the war and many countries of the
world discussed the sanctions which will
be applied only after the the fact
and i'm being very honest and that's
what i mean so
give us the reasons okay we're not in
the nato then okay tell us you're not in
the nato tell it openly we will never
get there
and
for
for and i'm addressing this to many
members of the alliance some of them do
say that some of them are afraid that to
say that some come here we shake hands
very warmly and they say us if it hadn't
been for that and that country would
have surely supported you others say
when everyone supports you we will
support you too why do we need to talk
about the future
we have risks here in the present
the next question channel 4 over there
oh
president
you have thanked the british government
for providing some anti-tank weapons but
what about the fact that london is a
center for the laundering of russian
money are you concerned that that will
undermine any sanctions and what do you
want the british government to do about
that
very complicated question
[Music]
i think those people
[Music]
who launder their money in london
they launder them
not only in that
capital city but in all capitals
where there is uh
posh real estate
or the business they like
or historically
money was
taken out
russia and i think it's not only russia
[Music]
the former soviet union republics
have a relation to this ukraine has
relation to that belarus kazakhstan i
don't want to offend
everyone that's why i said that it has
something to all these countries because
oligarchs
well there is such
chapter
in the history of the post-soviet
reality after
soviet union
disappeared countries became independent
and apart from independence
these countries received independence
but
together with independence they received
the oligarchy
and
i will be honest with you we are
actively
combating this
process in ukraine and we have achieved
quite a result
and
that these risks may be even
of higher priority than the
if it hadn't been for the escalation
this would be priority number one so
after escalation
and economy third one is combating uh
oligarchy and the legislation will
resolve that we have passed the law but
i don't quite understand
how can i help london
i think
i think this is the question
of the domestic
nature of
of great britain
this is about their domestic decision
i mean i can only say
when we
get rid of our own
go back to your your first answer and
just thinking specifically about the
russian threat
what is it that you know
that president biden doesn't know
[Music]
thank you for this question
what something that we know that
president
biden doesn't know as a president of
independent state i have it so i may
have
my own secrets just like the president
of the united states i think we have
very open
relations and now uh secret services are
sharing lots of information with each
other
but
you have to
feel the pulse on the day-to-day basis
you see
troops coming in and coming back and
withdrawing and pulled back
because there's different types of
information that is intercepted we
understand how these special
uh uh
troops are working under disguise
they're working on in the donbass and
many oblasts
on
of our country i don't want to to so
panic
uh um we we we are handling this with
our forces i would like to
to give you the example if you look only
at the satellite you will see
the increase of
troops
and you
can't
assess whether this is just a threat
or just
attack or simple rotation
[Music]
so
so our professional people they look
deep into it we see how they change
clothes the how they put the tent
uh that several brigades came
on
on the border but we can see that there
is no on the slide they have taken
the people
back out
so it's just only psychological they
would to to take to
make believe that they're there and that
that happens
closer to the big meetings normandy for
the minsk agreement so they're trying to
build up the psychological pressure
so
the
and we do see these things happening and
this is why we clearly understand
remember
we had the
the build up of troops in 2021 there was
the
peak of those
drills and there was a signal sent
by russia and some european countries
that it turned out that russia
started to pull back the troops and then
it was confirmed by
by many mass media and
the intelligence but our people saw that
the army wasn't pulled back they would
pull back several steps and then bring
them back and we saw it at that time and
we said that in
the early 2021 this was done just uh for
the for the show for
for their internal
uh
uh
constituency that the drills are over
we're not threatening anyone and we're
pulling back but
at that time
so i think that we these other things
these are the details that we see and we
we better understand
sky news i know that you have your crew
somewhere close to to the front line so
question is for you
expect that you are talking down the
threat of an imminent invasion just to
preserve your economy and actually the
americans are right it is a real
possibility that that can happen
imminently
is that what's really going on here
[Music]
thank you for this quest
it is very strange that i'm being
suspected of something
i think in my life i haven't done
anything to be suspected of things i
think you
mistake me for
another president of ukraine
i think first of all i
i'm the human being that first of all
should be the human being and the second
comes the economy and for me the
the question of the possible escalation
is not less
acute as for the united states and other
partners
not
leading managing the country just like
as in your uh
film uh don't look up
this was your
we're looking up
we don't understand uh what's happening
and we're talking about this
we're talking about this with our people
but uh we
have been in these situations for eight
years so we shouldn't be only looking up
we're also looking on the ground and for
us it's important it's an important
question
we
may lose the
economy of our country
people come first the
eminence of threat or the probability of
threat is there
in 2021
in 2020 it was less
in 2019
after
the normandy for
it was even less than that
day before yesterday there was a meeting
of the number 24 advisors i think
so there was a meeting
so indeed so if it's not just a
political theater
and this is very serious it means that
these are steps towards the dialogue to
move towards peaceful uh resolution of
this process this is why i think this
uh points to the fact that we have to be
very careful in how we speak out of
every day every minute
when we are trying to say that the war
will happen tomorrow we can't say that
the war will happen tomorrow please
believe me that the war will be uh
by the end of february or as they said
in november that the war will happen by
the end of the new year and then they
said happy new year but we have new
information
the war can happen in january and
february yes it may happen again
unfortunately and let's just put three
dots here but not just one full stop
and say yes for sure it will happen
because because we understand what's
happening to people then
the this these are courageous people but
the courageous people
have to protect
tree and keep on working at the same
time and keep on bringing up there and
nurturing their children because this is
life
is the third room to the right
bradley from nbc news um i'm just
wondering we see so much of what the
russians are doing in terms of
increasing their troop presence on the
borders what is it that you are doing
how are you preparing for what everyone
is describing except for the ukrainian
government as an imminent attack
[Music]
how we should act
we should um have no panic
we have a powerful
army
we have to
arm our armed forces
they have everything but is never
so
as much as we can provide considering
the capacity of our economy this is
about the economy again
with a powerful economy you can increase
the
equipped state of your armed forces uh
give them a better payroll they need it
and be increasing
their wages and salaries because so they
actually are put their lives let's take
15 000 people perished in this one you
know that
i think that
we are having this situation when we
fully trust in our armed forces they are
not novices
they are not rookies
they this a serious uh
body of um
soldiers um um for the nato level i
think that we are not worse than
any nato
nation in that respect we have the same
level we are on a level because we have
the lessons learned
uh the combat experience
the
experience of uh losing their friends
they protected their state defended they
should back
goods in afghanistan
military reconnaissance
force 1000 people evacuated in a very
experienced fashion so we have to do
everything to
make our army stronger and
god forbid we have this big war the
moral of our people will also be
a
defense asset
and people have to work for
our state for its economy and
for our armed forces which are prepared
to defend this state
there's a question from bbc the second
rule please
um mr president i wanted to understand
directly from you then i understand of
course this is a conflict that has gone
on for for many years i understand that
the threat from russia ebbs and wanes it
comes and it goes but could you tell me
directly
your assessment now of the threat from
russia to ukraine
and a further question if i may um
given that russia is making its view
extremely clear
about ukraine's possible membership of
nato i wondered from your perspective is
the
theoretical membership of nato at some
point in the future
or an ambition that's worth fighting for
thank you very much
[Music]
well
a proxy war
and
this is the proxy threat of threats in
plural
threats to ukraine and other countries
also in plural
we are not the only neighbor to the
russian federation we are not the only
neighbor to the temporarily occupied
territories with a full scale war
there won't be just a war with ukraine
or against ukraine or just in the
territory of our state this is going to
be a proxy war
um involves some cyber ops um and we are
trying to protect our sites but we can
understand where it is launched from the
russians another
destination so to speak
if we discuss war
with the
resultive firing this is one kind of war
this is the 20th century we are having a
difficult a different type of war right
now and we are in this situation we've
learned to protect ourselves and we are
very grateful for the assistance but we
have learned to
live with this and develop with this
and that's what i was talking about but
the threat is imminent the threat is
constant the proxy
threat i was discussing
it can be any kind of
strike
and
there can be
any kind of
grenade being
exploded
and
the
secret services
work to this effect there are many
things some subversive things many sides
i don't remember exactly but recently we
had this
something of the kind but we have
learned to protect ourselves to defend
those so this is our life we have to
lead
taking it globally as a global issue
that we are facing protection of human
life
there we can raise the issue of nato
membership the second part the latter
part of your question
and of course the security uh guarantees
it's not
being defended by somebody else's army
instead of our own
but we are talking about preventive
sanctions and i talked with the
president about that
and many interpreters nato is not about
war nato is about sanctions
to find some preventive measures nato is
one of such sanctions if it is not nato
then point to some other security
guarantees
tell me about those safeguards
one interesting thing
now we keep hearing
this powerful voice from germany
no hard feelings mind you but
they are telling us diplomatically
that for example if tomorrow we have
this buildup
on the part of the russian federation we
can forget about the north stream too
how should i interpret this
and here's why i have this reaction
yesterday when
this year the build-up and we discussed
them in the north stream 2 they would
say
if it is launched they said ukraine
will get
some security guarantees energy
guarantees energy security guarantees we
discussed that with germany with the
united states with the eu the sort of
guarantees we could expect
and we discussed that with the european
partners and the european partners in
that term had to discuss that with the
russian um interlocutors
the transit of gas for 10 to 15 years to
be prolonged at least to be renewed for
this period of the contract to that
effect with the
supplies from our european partners now
we can see how the discourse is changing
there nobody is talking anymore about
energy security for our state
they say if where they have the buildup
there's no
north stream two then
well
that's
the
proxy war for you
i understand that people have their
concerns they have the
challenges they have their troubles and
interests
which we call national but
you can also
have this fellow feeling for other
peoples
so when we are in nate
well
it's
not it does not depend on us when we
will be there unfortunately
is this a question
a request
what more could major non-nato allies
countries including australia be doing
to assist or support ukraine at this
stage
thank you very much for your question
[Music]
unfortunately i have to say that we are
grateful for the support already
rendered and i was talking about the
financial
safeguards don't
interpret this as some kind of lending
facility to stabilize our economy
but we need
stabilization for our economy with
investments fdi's coming from
some
country of origins now this is not
for the sake of
development but if somebody believes in
our stability and our future can lend
their help in hand not instead of
actually
undermining our
position
and they will come in
maybe for 10 15 um 100 percent so it is
too early to expect for the income the
income is the profit is for the future
the profit the income is in
the attitude talking of australia and
other partners you're welcome
invest in our
country please um demonstrate that you
believe in ukraine in ukraine you trust
and um
talking of nato i'm not
supposed to discuss nate in every single
answer given here but
we can see no alternatives for the
purposes of security
other countries if they are prepared to
offer some security option or defense
option or some other format of alliance
to provide assistance
uh real powerful assistance at a
particular
particularly difficult moment we're
prepared for this we are working on
such um
options this is very important you
understand so with the nature
so i dropped that line somehow
but
nato nations
what will they do
excuse this example but this is just an
example
we
are in this difficult situation
presently and that's why you're all here
and we are very grateful to you for
your attendance but if the war happens
tell me please which army of which
country will be prepared to defend us
no army no country it's not going to
happen
and this is very scary for nato
because if ukraine is in nato
and then
god forbid something
evil happens they will have to
end
their member
and this is a very serious challenge for
nature
but let me tell you this
some european countries think along
those lines and they count
on
having no risk with the ukraine as a
member but if there is this big war you
we have all been referring to here
and the war starts
it will be also at the borders of some
nato nations
for certain
and
we can expect some provocations there
because some of these countries
i used to be the soviet republic
in that day
and are you sure that
can you be certain that if the smaller
in terms of side nato may remember say
that we have an award at our borders are
you
convinced that they will be protected
defended or somebody is going to die for
their freedom and
statehood
wall street journal uh the first row and
to my left
you can see that they need it right
thank you so much for having us here uh
we just heard part of your speech to the
foreign ambassadors and we heard you
tell them
obviously that's your message here as
well i'm wondering beyond just the talk
of imminent war
if you're trying to
if you're at all concerned about some of
the divisions that are starting to come
to the surface within uh nato members
especially as they talk about the
imminence of war and then also their
differences start to become more vocal
so if you can talk about that and if i
may just one more question u.s secretary
of state tony blanken last week talked a
lot about the domestic politic political
issues that you're facing right now and
some of the struggles we saw former
president poroshenko in the streets just
a few days ago can you talk about how
concerned you are about that issue and
how it's challenging you to confront
this
um
the biggest risk for ukraine
and
the biggest risk for sovereignty of our
state and here we are united
um
i can tell you some uh this frankly
we're united with all our partners the
eu the united states the uk
our nato nations
now i cannot discuss some specific
detail
along those lines
you understand but what is very
important is that the biggest
risk is
to
fail to hold the country together this
is the domestic destabilization inside
the country this is the weakest link or
the most dangerous
dangerous prospect for ukraine i'm
talking about some economics here but
this is just one of the factors
the unity of leadership
trust and the president of ukraine
trust in the incumbent president and
understanding
on the part of
other politicians in this country that
they are former presidents or future
presidents they're not incumbent
presidents
this understanding wise
honest
and legit
makes our country
united and strong
and
if we are united
now as a people
with the army
with this stable leadership
in this
country the escalation risk coming from
the russian federation
uh will be considerably
diminished we remember developments in
2014 2015 in our country
the
lack of control of the situation inside
the country in terms of legality
on the
law enforcement board is
public order they can lead
when we have some actions
[Music]
from or on the part of the neighboring
country
in europe
what do you see here is one of the risks
it is um
caused by the
political activities of some
politicians some representatives of the
political elite of their country
that are making their own
and they are doing their own public
relations
i that's all i
did not see
any disturbances in our streets
we
see no disturbances and we can say that
um
what
is happening well when it's happening
for instance there's no uh some
somebody is uh on the leave and
everything is calm and peaceful
in the streets of ukraine
when somebody comes back that's somebody
people come to the presidential office
or block the parliament for that matter
but
it doesn't matter whether we have this
coveted pandemic and they have to vote
for um very urgent
[Music]
appropriation
to deter
the pandemic they don't care
i'm very happy that i have no political
background at first i was shocked
they don't care just don't care what is
happening in the country
there's a war we can do with that
business
we can deal with it
but on an everyday business they do
things
um using their
agendas and trying to present a schism
in our country
a division
um i wouldn't discuss on this topic at
length i would like to
discuss the things that interest you
because uh
i don't
like to talk about the past
that bygones
but i think that they are a product a
product of our legacy
the soviet legacy they represent the
oligarchs
tycoons
unfortunately
they can
have business they have
my generation
worked hard
to
have a business
and
it's that's some kind of people who
defend this they they they don't
privatize anything that exists when
the time of disintegration of the ussr
came
for
pennies and they we
um made our own fortunes in every penny
of it and we're defending this state my
generation let's talk about
this deutsche ballet the second rule
at the center while you are approaching
the mic please uh put one question so
that as many people can put a question
as possible
i would like to ask you've mentioned
nordstrom there's another discussion
about germany and that concerns delivery
of
weapons germany's providing helmets and
a field hospital but it has
categorically refused to send any deadly
weapons or other military equipment and
it has also had a role in other
procurements from other countries how do
you assess germany's role in this
conflict
i cannot say that germany
um
is to blame but because there are
several steps in several
forms
once germany
supported ukraine
supported on numerous occasions from the
very beginning with the reforms with the
normandy formats when the war started
chancellor merkel
made very important steps to resolve
the
situation
she had contacts with the russian
president to that effect
and i had a special relationship with
him that's the way i see it
and
presently we had this meeting my head of
office andre yearmark
reported that france
germany supported ukraine
trying to start negotiating
after such a long break or interval in
any kind of talks this is one
direction there's another one
where i think that germany
can do a lot a lot depends on germany
this is consolidation and the alliance
for support of ukraine
this is um their vision not just in
words but indeed
as
to the membership for ukraine in the eu
and you should be proud that your
state
has some such
and such an influence over the
other eu members
because of the economy historically so
there are many
answers to the question why
but this is on the on one hand on the
other hand you have to understand
that we are always aware of all this we
are aware of your influence over these
countries
that's why
we expect you to help us in that
area
for the lethal weapons this is only the
last
and the only
example this is not the first not the
only my example let me give you another
one
with the
energy
this year
and um
we had great difficulties
very
grave difficulties because of the
blockage of this
coal
supplies the
troops
around us the panic
no purchasing from russia and our coal
being obviously in the temporary occupy
territories
and then
what we have
in the territory we would bring it in
uh from the united states by sea we
needed natural gas because
our own wasn't sufficient for that we
know what russia did in that situation
we are aware of the details but at that
point we were approached by moldova
and they needed assistance
maya sandu
president said that our people are
freezing they talk to russia they
um
there was some
kind of um
concession and when the eu was supposed
to provide all the support for moldova
to demonstrate that some
a new young and energetic president um
um enjoy that support with the european
vision seeing moldova in the eu but
they started thinking about it with red
tapes
and some wheels within wheels being
considered but they are freezing now
and we gave her
gave her what we could as much as we
could
we gave her what she asked for we
did not expect
things that would happen two or three
months later and we did it so this is
about weapons
it is very important to
help when there is a need
a definite need this is a serious signal
issue this is a serious challenge
presented
i don't
wish that germany or the people of
germany don't don't wish that you
feel
in your own experience the same thing
around your borders like
what we have
i would never wish
this for anyone and i once told the
chancellor
merkel about
to i told her i understand that this is
business this atlantic process and so
forth but
just imagine that you have those troops
at your borders at your doorstep would
you arrange
north stream two with them in that
situation
so where's this contact line like we
have in
the
ukrainian donbass
for business
and reality where's the contact line
so i do not wish that you have
the same situation will
get out of this with flying and carlos
i'm sure but
i would never wish this
for you but uh if you have me in trouble
like this we will help you we'll be
there for you and can assure you
fox news uh closer to the uh
to the line here uh mr president thank
you very much for having us and thank
you very much for taking my question i
want to talk about two individuals
two questions number one
president biden
you've been critical of what some of the
things the u.s has been doing you've
been supportive what does he do wrong
what is he doing right
what do you want to see from him
and the second person
we've been in this long session and i
haven't heard this name once it's kind
of central to everything
russian president vladimir putin
what does he want what does he want to
get out of your country how can you deal
with them what kind of a threat is he so
president biden and russian putin
russian president
your thoughts
first of all i would like to say that
i don't want ukraine to be uh the
result of the agreement between
president biden
president
putin
president biden
recurrently assured me and yesterday as
well that nothing will be decided behind
ukraine's back about the destiny about
the current and the future of our
country this is a very
respected position and i do believe that
it is the case
president biden
[Music]
doesn't owe anything to ukraine
i'm not being critical of president
biden
i'm being critical of
anyone
[Music]
and myself as well
currently we live in the present day we
fight in the present day we survive in
the president we want to bring back our
territories we want to stop the war
i'm not being narrow-minded i see these
things i see these things in the broad
daylight we we've lived here for eight
years in this we know russia for much
longer than eight years we know that and
on there are people who support us on
the other side as well
and
and this is why
many of these doors i'm talking about
are closed uh but as a president of
ukraine i need to knock on all the doors
the the doors of all leaders and propose
different formats propose different
platforms
platforms for agreements not only the
the platforms where we can get the
result but at least to start the
the talks because when people are
talking there are no places for weapons
and that's a good start so what the
president biden can do i don't know
whether he can do i would like to
believe he can do that
and that he
will succeed
and that is to have a negotiation
platform
in
uh between us
the us russia and ukraine at least this
would be a parallel process
i'm not saying to choose between this
and the normandy former but again
we have to knock on all the tours
talk
look for common things start the
dialogue
and
stop for a minute and talk about the
humanitarian things
talk about nato about risk some want to
go to nato some don't want to be nato
but what do you propose as instead how
do you ensure energy security for
ukraine these are related things related
questions and i would like very much for
president biden and
i would like that and he knows that
each time we talk i'm proposing
different steps that
could come from our country i don't want
to go into details of this these are
these uh
[Music]
starting levels but we are talking about
this with him and i do believe that he
can help us because the united states
is a big economy is a big country that's
that's why
and what did you ask about putin i i
what is your feeling about president
putin what is he up to what does he want
how can you deal with them what is the
danger
what i think if
russia is communicating that they
support minsk
negotiations and they are not
going to attack ukraine
steps to to prove them true
i mean
why do you need so many uh soldiers
are there why do you need to have these
drills so often
i mean why drills they can do everything
they have a powerful army why do you
need drills to happen specifically
many years
some
where on on this side i mean there can
be any provocation
there is a big
just
the
mere fact of accumulating troops is the
big risk even if you're not going to do
something
it's still a high risk it still may
happen
why are you doing this to threaten
what is this side of masochism what is
the pleasure of this of someone being
afraid
we are not afraid but
there are people ordinary people who
live there who live in their houses they
are not uh
military people why what's the point of
this
uh why just to put our economy flat on
the shoulders
that's impossible
i mean
they're big people 40 we are big people
40 million plus is a lot we have
generations
growing up who will remember these
things they will never forget so
specific things uh concrete things if
you have a question let's sit down and
discuss i mean
i think the foreign minister federation
recently
it said again that if the president of
ukraine wants to
negotiate and and agree
have him come to the saint petersburg or
moscow or sochi
well first of all
why
and then he says but we can't discuss
questions of donbass there because this
is internal ukrainian
issue so why invite in this format
this way
for the person to disagree
because the way you put it
i mean you're
grown up why do you do it like that in
that manner
so i mean have nothing else to do why
are you proposing things
that won't work
so it means you don't care
whether the person has died on the
border or not today
so this is just blunt cynicism high
level
that's it
i mean how can i not talk about donbass
the whole world is talking donbass and
i as the president of ukraine shouldn't
care about what's happening on my board
the borders on the contact line and how
can you offer me something like this
what's what for
but i do want to meet i'm not afraid of
any format
of the meeting bilateral
okay i don't care i'm ready
why do you need to invite me to sochi
of all places for me what to ski there
i mean what are we talking about now
these this is serious things okay let's
meet an odessa let's swim in the water
there in the sea i mean i mean it has to
be serious people don't understand the
value of the human life and that's what
it's about
i'm
i do support the serious dialect
we have lots of challenges we have lots
of questions okay let's let's not
discuss all of them let's take one any
okay the exchange of prisoners
why do you care are you are you
uh getting satisfaction from people
sitting there in prisons like what's the
point
what is what is your historic victory in
this
so you will be in the history because
people were kept in prison there why
i mean i think this is the wrong
position in the first place it is
fruitless
it it's about someone willing to break
someone else getting the result you want
the life goes by and the minister
their minister is not as young a young
person and the life goes by
and new generations come we need to
agree we need to negotiate
uh luke harding from the guardian
newspaper in london um you've complained
about panic
um
one of the reasons people are panicking
is because the us and uk embassies
withdrew
their
um
non-essential personnel last week it's
happening now
mistake that decision in your view
yes
i think
it was a mistake
i
say this openly
i can't say that this is the mistake of
the governments of these respected
countries say this is this is our
mistake any for for us this is a mistake
the signals that we were getting from
the diplomats that these are
non-essential stuff i don't think so
under these circumstances everyone is
essential everyone should stay
to be honest in the city of mariupol
we have representatives of the
diplomatic corps of greece even in the
city of marupa which is on the contact
line where the contact line is very
close
where you can hear
cannons fire the greeks didn't take
anyone away i'm not comparing things i'm
not
i'm not comparing countries i just want
to tell you that
this is such an important message
everyone is looking at this everyone
understands
which
countries of eu respond how
the britain how the united states react
i think that
embassy
employees should
be here
these are the captains i'm sorry but
this is the captains of the diplomatic
cause they're the representatives of
their respective countries and the
captains are the the last who should
be leaving the ship and i don't think we
have a titanic here ukraine is moving
forward
abc news at the very end over there
and dear colleagues we we it's over an
hour so
we're coming close to the end just to
warn you
um you began by saying that you know the
details better than any other president
so i'm interested where in your judgment
white house and the pentagon are going
wrong and one other question if i may
if you're wrong you wouldn't be the
first ukrainian president to
underestimate russia have you thought
about that prospect
thank you
i think
your assessment
is not quite
precise of what i said
we are getting ready as much as possible
to any scenario and we have several
and
and by the way your countries are aware
of them of many of them we
we
secrets from our partners they
see this
they see that we are preparing as much
as possible that's what i mean
getting ready
versus saying
the
the what we are saying and specifically
are different things i think it has to
be a quiet
military preparation and quiet diplomat
diplomacy there are things we do share
with our partners at any case for
regarding any case of possible
escalation we do
all it takes on that side
we're it's not that we're acting as if
it's not the highest level of threat we
are getting prepared for the high
threats
but we understand the reality that we
are in
i can't
prove myself
right or wrong we
you see
these
hundreds of thousands of troops hundred
thousand troops there are no there is no
mistake there we do see them
the the risk
is that there are just too many of them
that there could be any provocation
and the probable escalation may be
triggered
accidental provocation or non-accidental
as you may uh gather it wouldn't matter
if there are
casualties and we may lose lots of
people i
that it will end up as it did in 20 back
in 2014 because first we didn't have
this kind of army at that time
and second is that people's perception
at that time was a bit different
now
well
firstly everyone is very patriotically
has a very patriotic mood
then secondly everyone has seen what has
happened on the temporary occupied
territory and they all perfectly well
know that this is not what they want
and this is why i am saying this is the
high risk because
it wouldn't be that someone will just
take a bit of something
it won't happen
informationally
no one
will able to do what russia said that
there was no presence of russia there
it's just all local people not in this
time
no local people
is not prepared to
take over government buildings
administrations they are not getting
ready for that and they are not doing
this we understand this very clearly
i'm discussing i'm describing you some
details that we're also sharing with
some of our partners something that we
often know
more we know the mood of the people and
this is not just uh
opinion polls
uh and numbers this is the reality we
visit these cities we talk to people
we walk the same streets we understand
clearly and precisely what's happening
so this time you can't say that local
people think that
they want to live in a different way
and uh
and it's not uh and russian will not be
able to say that we didn't occupy it was
civil war this time around it won't be
possible it would if it happens it will
be an open war
a horrible war we understand these risks
all of them
i'm just uh
i'm just doing
what i should
as the president of ukraine
the first part i forgot please get it
kenny can you ask for this the first
part was that you understand the
situation better than the other
president which seems reasonable so i'm
just interested where do you think the
white house and the pentagon are going
wrong in their analysis
[Music]
i don't think that the white house
is going very wrong in their analysis i
don't think so
i think
that they are
participating in this
informational situation that
is created around our borders
and because
the white house understands
that there are risks they keep
articulating this the key they keep
supporting this
theme this topic and they make it as
acute as burning as possible
and this in my opinion this is a mistake
this is just my personal opinion
because these are the signals
which says that this is how the world
responds and the world responds to
the information like that another
situation is the situation with the
diplomats the question that you were
asking
how would i put it i think
these
are redundant and wrong steps
that don't help us
right now they are not how these steps
are not contributing to our situation
uh
there is military support
other financial support for even when
financially support we we are grateful
for the support but uh
i
like i can't be like other politicians
who are grateful to the united states
just for being united states i'm
saying the truth we want to be partners
and true friends i don't want to lie to
you
my problem is that
i don't want to lie to you
we need to wrap uh up soon one or two
questions more please
pretty good mr president crystal gomez
and global news your chief of security
and national defense told me earlier
this week that it's not just about
troops but about
attack uh terrorist attack on key
infrastructure can you share any
information about any of those sort of
physical or cyber attacks that have been
identified or prevented
thank you for the questions we uh have
had quite a number of cyber attacks
we have prevented
those and
we did manage to
we did manage to
restore
and
recommission many
websites about government
institutions
in terms of the physical attacks i think
the strong how strong is our team as
strong as that we can preemptively
prevent knowing that there could be
casualties if we don't
some of the processes on the streets
that should have happened
our secret service have prevented very
strongly and our law enforcement has
worked very well we understood that
there will be very strong provocations
it is true and it was
well done i can't give details on how
our guys worked in this case but we can
see that this was
without casualties
we
there are things that we've been used to
by now we understand that this is a
problem it's when all the schools in
kiev
were reported to to be
bombs with bombs are mined so there were
phone calls warning that there are bonds
there so we understood where these phone
call calls were coming from these were
from the temporary occupied territories
from the crimea lots of cases like this
uh um
so they are done on the daily basis
there is an uh
action plan to make sure that we do not
lose any single
life not to have an explosions in the
schools
so far we are
managing to
uh to do
such things successfully but there's
lots of disinformation
at these
uh bomb uh reports to the schools and
taking the countries there's lots of
disinformation there's lots of calls
lots of warnings
we do find some of them even on the
territory of ukraine
uh we understand how that happens we
we even found people who have come from
the temporary occupied territory the
person came and they wanted to go back
they were
detained
there was uh the the consulate of the
russian federation was put on fire so
in live in the city of la viv
the consulate of russian federation was
put on far you understand this is a
provocation so
uh the very unpleasant
loads of them but
our law enforcement our
secret servers are working on the daily
basis to prevent this we understand that
we need uh
that they need a
provocation every day to disbalance the
situation inside ukraine so the last
question this
wrote to abc news please center
second question um there are all of
these negotiating diplomatic tracks that
are ongoing
some of the most important ones ukraine
doesn't even have a seat at the table
and russia's main demands are posed at
nato and in europe not even
ever give to russia to satisfy them do
you feel like
ukraine has been reduced to merely an
observer to its own face do you feel
like these countries are fighting over
ukraine rather than for ukraine
thank you for this question
you know
i don't know about all negotiations
although i
i
possess
quite uh
[Music]
signs of quite sizable information
and unofficial meetings of the leaders
of the countries
and uh the question that the
the ukraine has been discussed by these
leaders it's clear
the people meet and they discuss some of
the burning questions we want ukraine to
be
the entity
a subject
not to have outcomes that would
influence us without our participation
but i think according to in the
information that we know so far we
managed to
to achieve this
partners i think behind behave with us
in a
partner-like
approach or some of the things that we
mentioned today
are not
[Music]
completely clear to us but
nevertheless
the question
is who we are
and
how we feel ourselves to be and where
are we going and the most important is
the the
certainty
and i
am absolutely calm when i say that
ukraine is a
[Music]
independent state
it's a
respected state and
the
the decision will be with the people of
ukraine know well when this decide uh
instead of us even if these leaders
decide agree about something i'm sure
that these agreements will be
illegitimate and temporary in nature
thank you mr president thank you dear
colleagues
i do hope that you
received all the answers to your
questions and thank you for your
interest to ukraine
you